♪ ♪
>> THE RESOLUTION BEFORE US
TODAY IS ABOUT PROTECTING OUR
DEMOCRACY.
IT IS ABOUT PROTECTING THE
INTEGRITY OF THIS BODY.
IT'S BIGGER THAN THE CENSUS.
>> I TESTIFIED MYSELF FOR ALMOST
SEVEN HOURS BEFORE THIS VERY
COMMITTEE.
THIS IS JUST MORE POLITICAL
FIELD >> Bret: HOUSE JUST
VOTED TO HOLD THE SECRETARY OF
COMMERCE AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT, THIS AFTER THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR AT
SECRETARY ROSS WROTE A LETTER,
SENT A LETTER TO HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI SAYING "WE
REGRET THAT THE COMMITTEE
CONTINUES TO RECOMMEND THE HOUSE
WIELD ITS CONTEMPT AUTHORITY
EVEN THOUGH WE REMAIN WILLING TO
WORK TOWARDS AN APPROPRIATE
ACCOMMODATION.
BY TAKING THIS ACTION, THE HOUSE
IS BOTH UNNECESSARILY
UNDERMINING INTERBRANCH COMEDY
AND DEGRADING THE CONSTITUTIONAL
SEPARATION OF POWERS AND ITS OWN
INSTITUTIONAL INTEGRITY.
IF THERE IS NO INFORMATION TO
HIDE.
IF THERE IS NO INSTITUTIONAL
INTEGRITY TO CONSERVE, PRESERVE.
ACCORDINGLY WE PROPOSE THE HOUSE
POSTPONE THE CONTEMPT VOTE."
THEY DIDN'T.
MATTHEW CONTINETTI,
JONATHAN SWAN, NATIONAL
POLITICAL REPORTER FOR AXIOS,
AND JASON RILEY,
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" COLUMNIST,
SENIOR FELLOW AT THE MANHATTAN
INSTITUTE.
A LOT OF BREAKING NEWS, GUYS.
WE WILL START THERE WITH THE
CONTEMPT.
MATTHEW.
>> I'M REMINDED OF THAT MOMENT
EARLIER THIS YEAR WHEN
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR MET
NANCY PELOSI AT AN EVENT ON
CAPITOL HILL AND ASKED HER TO DO
BRING YOUR HANDCUFFS?
THERE'S SUCH A THEATRICAL ASPECT
TO ALL OF THIS.
IT'S PELOSI'S WAY OF KIND OF
FURLING TERM TO HER LEFT WING
BASE AND DRAGGING THEM ALONG IN
ORDER TO PREVENT THEM FROM JUST
GOING HOME FOR IMPEACHMENT.
BUT I HAVE TO SAY IF YOU'RE A
VOTER, AND AMERICAN VOTER AND
PAYING ATTENTION TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE HOUSE TODAY.
WHY ARE THEY ACTUALLY AGGRESSING
SO MIKE ADDRESSING KITCHEN TABLE
ISSUES?
SPEWING IN IT A WHITE BOARD FOR
ALL THAT WAS HAPPENING ON
CAPITOL HILL TODAY.
AS FAR AS THE VOTES.
JONATHAN.
>> ON THE CRIMINAL CONTEMPT
QUESTION, THE BULK PRODUCTION
THAT THE BILL BARR JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT GOING TO
PROSECUTE BILL BARR.
JUST A CRAZY PREDICTION.
THIS IS REALLY ALL ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS
NOW WHO BELIEVE THAT THE ONLY
WAY TO HOLD THE PRESIDENT
ACCOUNTABLE IS TO OPEN AN
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY AND TO DO
ALL THE INVESTIGATIONS CHANNELED
THROUGH THAT AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY STRIKING TODAY THAT THIS
IS SUCH A SMALL BALL FOR A LOT
OF THESE MEMBERS AND ASK THEM
WHAT DOES IS IT DRIVES THE
FRUSTRATION LEVELS UP EVEN
FURTHER AMONG THE PROGRESSIVE
FLANK.
EVERY TIME IS INCREMENT ACTIONS
HAPPEN, IT'S JUST NOT SATISFYING
THEM.
MATTHEW WAS SAYING IT'S JUST
THROWING TERM, AND THAT'S WHAT
IT IS, BUT THE TRAUMA IS NOT
SATISFYING THE PEOPLE.
IT'S MEANT TO SATISFY.
>> Bret: MENTORING
IMPEACHMENT, THE EFFORT TO BRING
UP ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT TODAY
FAILED IN THE HOUSE.
THE PRESIDENT REACTING TO THAT
ON TWITTER, AS HE OFTEN DOES.
JUST MOMENTS AGO.
THE UNITED STATES HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES HAVE JUST
OVERWHELMINGLY VOTED TO KILL THE
RESOLUTION ON IMPEACHMENT.
332-95-1.
WRAP THE MOST RIDICULOUS AND
TIME-CONSUMING PROJECT I'VE EVER
HAD TO WORK ON.
IMPEACHMENT OF YOUR PRESIDENT
WHO HAS LET THE GREATEST
ECONOMIC BOOM IN HISTORY OF OUR
COUNTRY, THE BEST JOB NUMBERS,
BIGGEST TAX REDUCTION, REBUILD
MILITARY AND MUCH MORE IS NOW
OVER.
THEY SHOULD NEVER BE ALLOWED TO
HAPPEN TO ANOTHER PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AGAIN."
JASON, HE SEEMS TO BE RELISHING
THIS KIND OF FIGHT THAT HAS
DEVELOPED.
>> SURE.
HE'S CERTAINLY RELISHING IT.
IT'S DIVIDING THE OPPOSITION, IS
ALWAYS GOOD FOR THE INCUMBENT,
BUT NANCY PELOSI IS IN A DILEMMA
HERE.
SHE HAS MODERATES IN HER CAUCUS
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO BE BACK
HOME AND PANNING ON THIS NEXT
YEAR.
SHE DOESN'T THINK IT WILL HELP
DEMOCRATS NEXT YEAR IN ELECTION
SO SHE'S TRYING TO HOLD OFF BUT
SHE HAS THIS PROGRESSIVE WING
THAT WANTS TO GO THERE.
AND THAT'S HER DILEMMA RIGHT
NOW.
BUT ALL OF THESE SUBPOENAS AND
CONTEMPT CITATIONS, THIS IS
ANKLE BITING ON THE PART OF
DEMOCRATS.
THEY WON'T REALLY PULL THE
TRIGGER WITH IMPEACHMENT, AT
LEAST NOT YET, THIS IS WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IN THE MEANTIME.
WHEN REPUBLICANS CONTROLLED THE
HOUSE, THEY CITED ERIC HOLDER.
AND IT HAD ABSOLUTELY NO IMPACT.
>> Bret: NEXT WEEK WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE, WE THINK, THE MUELLER
TESTIMONY ON WEDNESDAY.
AT LEAST WE THINK IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
TODAY YOU HAD THE FDNY SAY THAT
ESSENTIALLY THE CASE ON THE
CAMPAIGN FINANCE IS OVER.
WE DON'T KNOW IF ANY INDICTMENTS
WILL COME LATER, BUT THERE'S NO
INDICTMENTS NOW.
SO IT'S LIKE WHERE'S THE BEEF?
>> THERE'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
POINT ON THAT TO UNDERLINE,
WHICH IS THAT THESE ARTICLES --
THE ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT
DRAFTED BY REPRESENTATIVE AL
GREEN, THERE IS NO MENTION, IT
IS PURELY BASED ON THE
PRESIDENT'S -- WHAT HE DESCRIBES
AS THE PRESIDENT'S RACISM.
HERE'S SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT.
THIS IS NOT SOME LITTLE FRIENDS.
THIS IS NOT A SMALL LITTLE
PROGRESSIVE WING.